what's joining me now is the shadow
secretary for digital culture media and
Sport Lucy Powell a very good morning to
you Lucy Powell thanks so much for
talking to us and let's talk about some
gray shall we it looks like she's going
to be joining your team it's not gone
down too well with many conservatives or
the instituted government actually how
appropriate is it to make that
appointment
well care has made no secrets over the
last few months that as we head towards
uh the next general election that he was
looking to strengthen his team with
someone who could bring experience from
government and how government works in
order that he and the rest of the Shadow
cabinet indeed the labor party could be
better prepared for the eventuality of
us winning that next election because
Kia has got big ideas about how he wants
to change the way in which government
works he wants to devolve huge amounts
of powers out to the regions and nations
of the UK he wants to reorient uh
government to deliver on missions
working with business and trade unions
and Civil Society these are things that
have not been done for a long time and
he doesn't want to waste any time after
the next election should we win it in in
trying to work out how to do that so
he's been looking for uh somebody with
that experience and I'm too great you
know has got the reputation of being one
of the very best uh senior civil
servants of our time and of course her
appointment will be subject as your um
your correspondent just said there will
be subject to the advisory committee on
business appointments and both kirst
armor and Zoo gray have said that they
will abide by the recommendations of
that committee unlike uh many uh recent
uh recent cabinet ministers who who also
have been subject to that committee
but allies of Boris Johnson are saying
today that the Sue gray report now looks
like a left-wing stitch up is it going
to be hard to fight that accusation if
secure makes her his chief of staff
I think this is a an utterly ludicrous
uh suggestion uh nobody including Boris
Johnson and all of his key allies
seriously refuted or uh challenged uh
the findings of that report when when
they came out indeed quite the opposite
I think Boris Johnson said sue Graves
report had Vindicated him and he then
went on to fire a number of senior aides
of course the police uh then
investigated a number of the findings
and issued a large number of fines to
people working in number 10 and D the
Prime Minister himself and of course at
the time that Sue gray was appointed to
do this report let's not forget that the
previous person the Prime Minister had
appointed had to recuse themselves
because there were allegations that he
had also been taking part in these
parties that the Prime Minister and all
his key allies at the time lauded Sue
gray for her formidable
impartiality and Independence and her
professionalism and because she is a
revered and uh you know of high repeat
civil servants uh in in government and
and they all lauded that at the time and
I think any suggestion that Sue gray was
party to some kind of conspiracy here is
is frankly doesn't stack up to the
evidence and is for the birds
during her time as a senior civil
servant she would have been privy to
some very sensitive information not just
about policy making but also also about
misdemeanors and wrongdoing when she was
in in a in a role governing ethics so
given that she has that privileged
information is it appropriate that she
then works for an opposition party who
could use that information
there is no suggestion whatsoever and no
chance whatsoever of Sue gray uh
spilling uh the beans in that way and
that is not at all why she has been
appointed by kissed armor she has been
appointed to help Kia and the shadow
cabinet with their preparations for
government with those big Ambitions
we've got about changing the way the
country Works to change the lives of
ordinary uh people Sue gray has of
course as a civil servant has worked for
successive governments of Labor of
conservative colors successive Prime
Ministers many of whom the recent
conservative ones Theresa May Boris
Johnson Liz truss rushy sunak many of
whom hated one another and had different
agendas to one another there's been no
suggestion uh whatsoever that sugray or
other members of the civil servant
service haven't acted totally properly
and in confidence in those situations
and of course her appointment will now
be subject to this in independent
advisory body who may well recommend a
period of of gardening leave and we will
abide by that and so we'll sue great
and am I right in saying that the Prime
Minister has the ultimate decision on
this and if that's the case will you
respect what Rishi sunak rules
we we have said we will that Sue gray
and kirst armor will respect and uh
stand by the recommendations of the
advisory committee on business
appointments and there is usually a
recommendation of a period of gardening
leave and I think that is something that
that cures Dharma and the General
Secretary of the labor party have have
taken into account because as I say this
this appointment comes at a particular
time in the cycle as we are perhaps a
year 18 months away from the next
election and it's about somebody coming
in and helping us with those
preparations of government that is a
different role to the role that we have
uh other people doing uh Morgan
McSweeney our campaign director Shabana
but mood our national campaign
coordinator who have over the last year
or two really transformed Labor's
election operations are so-called attack
and rebuttal our digital campaigning our
Communications and so on they're
responsible for that work and and
actually that is quite separate in many
ways from the role that Sue will be
coming in which is about making sure
that if and when we win the next
election we can really hit the ground
running and make the changes that we
want to see at the top of government
right across the country so that we can
change people's lives for the better and
that's what this is about
I just wonder if I can ask you just one
quick question
um given that you're from Manchester
you're also an MP for a Manchester
constituency I wonder what your reaction
was to yesterday's report into the
Manchester Arena bombing
well yes thank you I'm the obviously the
MP4 for the arena area and
Sir John Saunders uh public inquiry has
been very very necessary but incredibly
difficult and the report the third
report that was out yesterday will make
very difficult reading for the families
of the 22 people who lost their lives
and all those families of those who were
physically or mentally injured in that
attack and as a city our thoughts remain
with them first and and foremost and it
is of no comfort really when you read
that there were serious and significant
missed opportunities that were missed it
is of no Comfort when people uh really
apologize or say that they will learn
the lessons but we absolutely both must
learn the lessons we must enact those
lessons and constantly review those
lessons so that whatever is necessary
can happen in the future to avoid such a
terrible terrible attack as this
Lucy pal we appreciate your time today
thanks very much indeed for joining us